frustration is mounting in France many
people are angry about the government's
harsh austerity policies including
Christine of Yanni the government is
planning public spending cuts of 50
billion euros caption option key fob
younger anxious our work creates
additional wealth if we didn't work
there wouldn't be a cake to share out in
the first place so the government is
doing exactly the opposite of what it's
supposed to be doing they should
increase wages not reduce them economist
philippe crudele says the tough stance
taken by the labor unions is a problem
in comparison to Germany it's extremely
difficult to implement reforms in France
off also not by traditional accessories
the parties don't easily agree on things
here first the union's flex their
muscles by going on strike if that
doesn't work they might negotiate it's
different in Germany the parties start
with discussions and they only take to
the streets if that doesn't work welfare
like it over without the 50 test
jean-jacques Urian is pleased the French
government wants to help businessmen
like him by cutting corporate taxes and
10 billion euros in ancillary wage costs
but he says those measures won't be
enough thank you sir nada mas de Manila
back so the austerity plans are going in
the right direction but they don't go
far enough they're just minor reforms
and putting them into action won't be
cheap correo makes sport uniforms and
equipment but he says it's hard to keep
up with the international competition
look sick bay i couldn't equate
associate our competitors mainly come
from Asia we have to match their prices
although our production costs are up to
15 times higher than theirs these are
kill sweat suit guy al correo thinks the
French government should make it easier
for companies to lay off staff but in
his opinion for small businesses like
his the worst hindrance is bureaucracy
don't say got busy kill us post the
simplest payroll calculations of 16
different entries that means you have 16
different kinds of contributions the
system is unbelievably complicated cool
pixie takes their difficulties facing
French companies are impacting the labor
market the economy is stagnating more
than ten percent of the workforce is
unemployed crevel believes Frances
neighbor Germany knows the secret to
recovery the country also pushed through
hard reforms let me give an example if
also Germany is a real role model the
country as a 200 billion euro export
surplus while in France we import a lot
more than we export the German budget is
balanced unlike in France and German
companies are more competitive their
profits are higher in France typical
profit margins are around only
twenty-five percent the event simple sir
but not everyone in France looks to
Germany as an example of how things
should be Germany is anything but a role
model for us they only talk about
productivity in France we think about
the people who are responsible for that
we introduce the minimum wage first and
now Germany is copying that from us with
so much frustration at home Frances path
out of the economic crisis is likely to
be fraught with difficulties